on my 18th birthday I asked for you to
go buy us a joint and you and I were
going to walk around the park and smoke
a joint and just talk do you remember
that no you don't remember that no on
the day of my 18th birthday you I that
was what I asked for I asked for the day
before I go y I want to tomorrow I want
to smoke a joint with you and just walk
around the park and talk and you said
okay and you cleared it with Mom y all
thought it was okay yeah you went uh
bought a joint actually I think you and
I walked in together yeah we went into
Buds and Roses shout out Buds and Ros
buds uh you bought some stuff I bought
some stuff and then we went to vnso down
the street from our place with that
giant track right with the four baseball
fields and we smoked the joint and
walked around the park for like an hour
that was the first time we smoked to
that was the first time we smoked we
together I that memory just flooded back
into my brain holy [__] that's what I
asked for on my 18th birthday I was like
obviously like you guys get me the
presents you want but like the gift that
I want this year and the sentimental
gift that I want is this why was that
just out of curiosity I don't know I
feel like honestly truthfully it was
like I felt like it would be like you
think mushrooms is I I thought it was
going to be a bonding experience because
I smoke weed with all my best friends so
I was like well I I guess I would love
to see what level this relationship is
at I guess in my head and how'd we do
great I mean look we're we're here
now like for me I think it just
furthered the notion that like yeah
we're friends like we're you're my
parent and that's the respect part but
like we're also like we're friends we're
buddies we can talk about anything and I
think that one really kind of just
pushed that narrative a little more
forward for me and I think honestly also
I just think I wanted to smoke weed with
one of my parents yeah I would be the
one yeah you're not smoking weed with
your mom no no she's not smoking weed no
she did a CBD strain once though yeah I
remember I was there for that I found it
it actually worked great great and then
the next time we tried it it did not
yeah it's just not for everybody you
know totally fine but you know not a lot
of kids say they smoke weed with their
parents and I was like I also would like
to have that under the books I I I I
this
is I now remember that it's crazy that I
didn't remember that it's dude it was so
long ago you and I have smoked a lot of
weed since then so not together just
separate but I've done a couple drugs
since then too so I how would you feel
about going to get our brains checked
out
we can I'm down my I know my short-term
memory is going to be
[__] so I'm prepared for that I want
them to do a like take a couple pictures
of your brain I feel like it's going to
be like the concussion test that I had
to go do yeah but this is going to be
way more in depth yeah and I didn't pass
the concussion test well after the
concussion at least yeah this yeah this
is not this is I I'm I'm nervous too but
I think it'd be something that we should
do